[Music]
when christian and i were kids we had a
few different babysitters our favorite
or my favorite babysitters were there
were three teenage boys who lived that
sounds weird now
who lived around the corner from us
named the parisies
and they were very impressive the key is
they played football they were high
school football players and at the time
when i was five six seven years old i
was obsessed with football either one or
two of them at a time
would occasionally babysit for us and
one time when they did i wanted so badly
to impress them that i set up a shrine
in my bedroom of the football helmet i
had and all my favorite football cards
and filtered through my six or
seven-year-old brain i thought they
thought it was cool but looking back
they must have been kind of freaked out
oh that's why you got the restraining
order against you
i always wondered what that was for oh
you thought it was just random yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
from wondering this is justin long and
you are listening to life is short life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is christian hi
justin hi christian that continues to be
weird
we normally don't call each other by our
first names um but
you are named christian so speaking of
the preseasons they were kind of the
idealized version of our
family and that we we were three
brothers they were three brothers they
were older than us but they were not
that you know not to put us down too
much but they were very handsome and
friendly and athletic they played sports
so they were kind of i always saw them
as people that we aspired to be you know
as a kid yeah that's true they were
definitely our physical um superiors
well we were also little boys they were
they you know they had but even once we
became teenagers they looking back i
think they were physically superior
but you don't know that because you're
like they were your vision of them
varsity football players not all varsity
football players are really good-looking
no not necessarily good looking but more
physically impressive than we are yeah i
don't mean just their faces is that when
you think you hung up on their faces
they had really nice faces i think they
did two of them are twins uh-huh
remember there was an oldest chris and
occasionally we would get chris and that
was like he was like tom brady
i feel like we talked about how handsome
tom brady's
a lot
way too much do gay men like tom brady
and and i fetishize his looks as much as
straight men and i would say
probably not
that would be my guess we're certainly
not qualified to answer that but i don't
think we can i don't think it's possible
to answer that besides the parise
brothers my favorite babysitter was
named shelly i think and she was um
i remember her being really pretty
she i think she had like kind of a val
it was the first valley girl accent that
i was ever exposed to and now of course
that's a very common thing you see that
on a lot of reality shows
that like a lot of them talk like that
you know that's like a very yeah that's
how she talked she did she was sort of
like like whatever oh my god yeah we had
never heard that before because we grew
up on the east coast we grew up in
connecticut so it wasn't a very you know
that's a very like orange county
um l.a area accent which has now become
so popularized that i think a lot of
girls talk like that a lot of guys talk
like that too well speaking of nannies
and babysitters we have on the show
today
arguably the most famous nanny in the
world i think or one of them uh fran
drescher who starred as the nanny on the
cbs show the nanny that's true it's the
first time that occurred to me that she
is probably the most famous
nanny who else what other i mean when we
were kids mr poppins oh yeah of course
of course in fact
but mary poppins is a fictional
character
and as you as you guys are about to find
out fran drescher is in fact real
that's right that's true uh
mr belvedere and
actually in the 80s charles in charge
who's the boss tony danza yeah in fact
charles in charge scott baio and and
tony danza really reminded me of of the
priesty boys i think just because of the
context and also they were of italian
american descent and they had that kind
of like swarthy
vibe
swarthy vibe that's so your taste
that's my
taste in boys
and boy babysitters
well i had never met fran before justin
had he he did a movie with her um yeah
we did a movie called safe space she
played your mom which i thought it was
sort of insulting to her casting wise
that she
well only because she's so
young-looking yeah that's true
it's hard to believe that she would be
your mother i was a little nervous about
her casting only because i i knew her
only as
pretty much as the nanny um and i
knew her to have such an indelible voice
and and and laugh but one that was so
specifically new york i mean
specifically queens new york what were
your impressions of her before doing the
movie aside from her voice had you ever
seen the nanny i had never seen i don't
think i've ever seen the nanny i had
seen like scenes from it but i never sat
down and watched start to finish an
episode i never saw any of it but i i i
knew that voice and that laughs so
well
oh i mean i i can say this now because
i've met since met her and really like
her well what did you think of the voice
before i thought it was so [ __ ]
annoying which is why
probably why i never saw the show
who would want to watch 30 minutes of
that that's interesting you found her
the the voice grading before
and
and
now you find it endearing well you'll
have to wait for the end of the
interview to find out what i thought
what a tease spoiler alert i like it now
uh no i thought so we when we recorded
this interview in her apartment which
which is the first time we did this for
your first time meeting her first time
meeting her but also the first time
we've done one of these shows in
someone's home that's true
so it was a very yeah
unusual experience especially because
she lives
in one of obviously an amazing apartment
in new york city but one of those
apartments that overlooks central park
and you know i've always walked by those
buildings and and and wondered who must
live there and yeah but i've never been
inside one of those apartments one of
those insanely
fancy apartments and the funny thing
about fran's apartment is that it had
also the previous residents had all been
themselves
famous
jewish women like iconic jews iconic
jewish women like madeleine khan right
madeleine county or was it carol kane
maybe carolyn kane maybe both it was a
great apartment and she and her friends
were there and it was very inviting and
warm it felt very homey i'll tell you
what wasn't warm and inviting and uh
enjoyable
her dog
she has
a little pomeranian oh that's samson
samson
that you will hear in this interview
because oh you're all so lucky you're
going to get to know the pant it was
such a pant she he's a panther
and sure enough she couldn't explain why
you'll hear him panting yeah it's really
funny um any any and she's like just
don't let him near you cause he bites
and i was like oh my god what's
redeeming about this dog
but fran is as you'll hear one of the
warmest people one of the nicest i'm so
grateful that she sat down because i
want other people to know
her and um hopefully you'll get to know
her a little better after hearing this
coming up right after this
my sweet friend fran drescher
life could be a dream
[Music]
we might hear dog barking from the next
oh that's part of this that's part of
the table setting okay
[Laughter]
so you know at some point we may have to
bring him out but he's a what is wrong
with panther he pants a lot and it's
hard when you're trying to record you
know he also nips a little he fear bites
under certain circumstances that we're
realizing are pretty consistent so his
so he wouldn't bite you
is but you're attracted to him you still
find him beautiful well first of all i i
got him with my second ex-husband no you
have three two two you know i got rid of
the husband but the dog that's just like
him
i had to keep
what am i going to do with the dog he
didn't want the dog did he want that
does he miss the dog
he doesn't
talk to me
[Laughter]
i have nothing but gratitude
and uh but now you're stuck with no bad
feelings samson
yes why samson because from the time he
was a tiny puppy
he was stuck up for himself we had a dog
a family dog we named biggie smalls
because he was big on attitude and small
on size he was this tiny similar thing
uh so but a couple months into owning
this biggie smalls dog my parents my
mother called me one night she said
i i
i was just watching a a show on vh1
behind the music and did she was did you
name our dog after a gangster rapper
i never heard that word pronounced with
both ours a gangster rapper um so what
kind of dog
so samson is out and made a beeline for
fran
[Music]
oh yeah you can hear him panting give me
a little cup of water oh can you who is
it you could call him we should call him
moses he's been like walking in the
desert oh no he don't want to let him
oil he doesn't need water he's not
really i think he may need water but
this is my morning lemon oh oh yeah so
this is part of your your routine you
have a very strict organic
diet picked up on on two dudes that i
dated one was indian that was the second
husband and the other one is jamaican
and they both you know uh drank lemon
water every day and they said that is
the way to live a long and healthy life
lemon water every morning first thing
i thought
maybe this is the universe giving me a
message yeah through these two dudes
something to take away i live by almonds
you know
ilsenia they say in italian what does
that mean the sign
okay so signs are very important yes so
that's why you've kept samson and you're
very good to samson probably because
maybe that was something that your
ex gave you i was always more into
animals than kids but as i get older you
know i do
like the innocence of them they're so
freaking
sweet and playful
yeah everything i but i have always
liked having kids at uh you know like
funerals and shiva houses why
because they had an energy of life yeah
that's true and you start talking to
them and it's like it's just a reminder
that there's a continuum yeah i mean
this is maybe too heavy but does that
make you sad that you don't because you
did not have kids do you have an
awareness sometimes i think and this is
honestly only recently
should i have uh adopted a kid or should
i have
had a a kid or is it too late to have a
kid and i kind of feel like maybe it is
too late did i miss
a very
key
experience because i'm all about you
know having the experience
and it's a ride sure and i'm like am i
missing the big experience
that you know i mean it could ruin your
life too
i think you i think we're just
determined i know i knocked myself in
and out of it in two minutes this is
where i go every time there are certain
kids that you're around and and my i
think my nephew is one of them where it
makes you want to have you know they
just they're so like lovely it's
something i've thought about i've turned
40 and i you know i'm not in a
relationship so i i see all of my
friends people that i am close to in age
they're having kids and they're
experiencing that and and of course i
see it all filtered through like social
media for the for the most part which is
only the good stuff that's why you can't
i mean when i look at pictures of me
with my ex-husband yeah and videos where
we're laughing hysterically and
everything i mean it's everything you
kept for a reason is that hard not to
i mean is that hard for you to not uh
miss him miss that missed those times no
because look we had three years together
the first year was bliss and i thought
wow this is so
great that at my age i should have this
kind of
unbelievable experience of
love and excitement and wonder you're
flush you're but i i knew that you were
like a new real
group
you got your groove more than back
heaven on earth yes i had for year one
and i have no regret second year agony
and ecstasy wow okay so starting with
that third year just uh
so it's okay because that first year was
so such a rush such a high yeah so
incredible and then also the arc of the
relationship i learned so much about
myself
that i had to experience it i'm all
about
you know this is a huge classroom for
you yeah and everything that comes at
you is your opportunity on your journey
of self-refinement it's like a game
board if you're not gonna learn from
your life well that's the thing this is
so short i mean the time that we have
and that's something we should talk
about and like you know better than
anyone how precious this time is yeah i
do i do
you know i was a victim of violent crime
in my 20s yeah i learned when people in
their 20s should not really be thinking
about how ephemeral life is how it can
really change
on a freaking dog
this happened in your 20s it's something
you've spoken about yeah the rape
someone broke into your house yeah and
he was on parole
oh my god i know how's that in
california yes and he had a friend with
them two men a brother
oh my god and was he did was he caught
eventually yes thank god i am one of
those victims that had closure
there were a lot of
you know break-ins and
rapes in my small area community
in the valley
you know and i have like a photographic
memory i decided
that i needed to study the details of
this person's face
and it was at a certain angle i was
working with the police um artist
you know he wanted to do a flat face and
i said can you do it at the angle that
i'm
seeing it in my head yeah and he said
sure and he drew it
and that night
of the stakeout they see a white car
running park double park
somebody gets into the passenger's side
and they start pulling away
and just before
they're about to get on the freeway they
pull them over
that was the night he raped his last
victim and her jewelry was hanging out
of his pocket
the detective had the police sketch that
i
did with him wow
and the detective said this is you you
[ __ ] you're under arrest it was
like he had sat and posed for no kidding
i always wonder how accurate those are
well
i made a point amazing of look because
the detective on tv said you must look
for very specific
you know unique characteristics well
something that awful and traumatic is
happening which i can't even relate to i
you had the presence of mind to study
this ironically i was the only one that
wasn't
gagged
oh my god but our friend judy was there
and she was also raped and my first
husband was there and he was completely
tied up and and and how long did they
how much time are they
did you ever try the best who was on
parole of course got like 125 years old
oh good
guys no parole oh good
yeah because there were so many uh you
know did you speak with other victims of
his that that you know they must have
been so appreciative three busloads of
victims that were called down to pick
him out of a witness line but school
buses
what he said i was on a rampage
so what happens
afterwards after something like that
i um
i wasn't completing my sentences and
though i didn't realize that it was
pointed out to me by some department in
the city that uh speaks to rape victims
yeah and determines whether what i don't
know what we're maybe that you need
therapy or something but
uh
talking and then i would kind of like um
drift off like um and stop talking and i
did not even realize because i would go
into my mindset thinking about what
happened yeah my god this is why i
remember it so vividly because you
almost think that you're okay
yeah and then i'm in a restaurant and
the um
i guess bus boy or server dropped a tray
that made a huge noise
without even thinking about it leaped to
my feet and screamed
in this restaurant so everyone was
looking
and i kind of slink back into my chair
and are you and are you aware in that
moment like oh it's because of this i
mean
how often would things like that happen
before you were like i gotta start
talking to somebody about it
well you know i got a uh
a movie shortly after that and at that
point you know we kind of needed the
work because it this whole thing set us
back and was we oh you you know my
husband and we lost and we lost so much
things oh my gosh
we had
some insurance but but are you thinking
wow [ __ ] that stuff i mean i'm alive i
mean is there a pr is any part of you
that is
going through this this sense of
euphoria even i mean i know you've been
through this horrific thing but there's
also a sense that you did not die i mean
the worst didn't happen
you
keep getting locked into the horror of
the moment when the front door was
broken down
and they started charging into the house
oh my god waving guns
and then the therapist tells you
do not get locked into that moment of
horror you have to
walk your mind through the experience
and they laughed
and you lived
and the detective said if you lived
through something like that you did
everything right
don't beat yourself up because
i pulled a knife out of the knife rack
before they came to me and then i
thought
no i shouldn't put it back and i did and
so i think i was beating myself up about
that that i shouldn't have i should have
just done it
you knew but i got scared of course i
mean i i often i think about thing i
shouldn't but i think about what if
something like that happened i mean i
think oh i i would like to think that i
would do that grab a knife right but
then the reality of actually doing
plunging a knife into it i saw they had
guns
and at the time especially i was
completely unconscious to this but i had
a superwoman
you know like issue i mean i i was
everybody superwoman and everybody's
caregiver
so you know i
i felt like i had failed why was this
can you track why that was i mean was it
the way you were growing up and yeah
yeah i am well yes in my home this is in
queens yes this is my home
me and my sister are like a year apart
and she was i think the high strong one
in the family took up a lot of room yeah
my mom was the nervous one and my dad
was the stoic one and i was the youngest
where i got my positive reinforcement
was to be the needless one
and be the caregiver yeah not have not
have needs of my own but take care of
everyone else's needs a very similar
familial dynamic i think that's yeah
yeah one of many reasons why we get
i think but do you still have that
dynamic because your parents are still
alive and um and as is your sister so do
you right
now not as
no not as much because i myself
have changed yeah yeah i've really done
a lot of work on myself and i think
actually
that was the silver lining of getting
cancer i think the cancer
was part and parcel of not really
dealing with the rape and poetically
ended up a gynecologic cancer oh you
think what just manifested itself
because of what how that trauma lived in
your body deal with it i did the movie
and i just kind of brushed it under the
carpet
and uh and now you have cancer so it has
to be about you so now it was my license
to make it about me as pathetic as that
sounds i had to get cancer
to say
you know i need help
i can't do this alone you know the
universe
keeps giving you these signs and these
messages yeah they start out
nice and subtle
soft-spoken and then two guys come
running through your door and then
eventually if you have to get hit over
the head with a hammer yeah to wake up
and freaking get the lesson that your
soul needs to
figure out on this
you know leg of your journey yeah but
what do you think how what do you think
that message was now in hindsight i mean
what what was the message you failed you
always needed to
become a more well-rounded person
and become vulnerable and i didn't do
that
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
yeah did you call peter i said i think i
have the idea peter was your husband
yeah right now my gay ex-husband yes yes
he was at the time your straight current
husband exactly
and this is someone you met in high
school right we we're 15. 15. we
remember the exact moment that we saw
each other he was the pianist for the
drama club oh okay and i was in the play
but that wasn't even the first time we
saw each other it was uh in the hall in
the stairwell
and he was coming down the steps and i
was going up and we laid eyes on each
other and he still you know i mean he
didn't want the divorce really yeah he
did not want it he didn't want to break
up our marriage and so the minute you
know he was free to explore his true
orientation he ultimately
became i think a happier person i'm sure
do you ever look back at that and and
replay certain moments and think oh god
i should have known then i mean like
absolutely
i was saying how did you not know
let me just put in the context that men
were starting to take care of themselves
differently yes all of that stuff
emerged from the metrosexual genre
and when we were coming up
uh saturday night fever that was my
first job
and in that movie john travolta's blow
drying his hair that's right the pants
were very tight so you guys were
starting to take care of their their
quaff their hair i was a teenager when i
got that part but that was the beginning
of that whole period what was it like
we're meeting travolta you must be going
he was in he was a sweat hog at the time
on welcome back oh yeah a sweat hog yeah
yeah yeah who's your star he you know he
was a huge tv star yeah this is his
first movie
and uh
i love them from the tv show he was so
funny on that show and yeah great time
funny and cute and that whole i mean it
goes to show you what timing is because
that whole kind of new york thing was
very popular
so i was right at the right place at the
right time because i was never nervous
when i take meetings so i would be very
chatty yeah
very confident
very comfortable in my own skin
pretty yeah very young and so i started
the book yeah and and
i wonder why you weren't nervous were
you did you perform in high school how
did that i did perform in high school
but the dressers are very outgoing
people okay you know
when you say you got your i love this
story you got your laugh from your mom
and and were you telling the story well
uh the whole voice you know my parents
are like satellite celebrities yeah and
even rosie o'donnell had them on as
early bird restaurant clubs they
reviewed restaurants in florida they
were on the nanny quite a lot too yeah
so yeah and their names are perfect
morton morty and sylvia
so they um
they were asked once did you realize
that fran had a
funny voice when she was growing up and
my mom in the same voice said we never
knew she had a funny voice
i like that you laugh when you really
there's there are a couple different
versions of it but my favorite one is
when you ramp up into it it's like it's
like a like an act like a long jumper
running up to his mark
[Applause]
and now people say to me what do you
want on your tombstone and i say her
laugh made us laugh
that would be cool that is it's true and
what a what a gift before sarah knight
fever you were
was that miss teen you were missing a
new yorker miss new york teenager but i
got an agent telling everybody i was
miss new york teenager oh i was missing
a teenager
interrupted yes now who beat you oh some
blue eyed blonds
[Laughter]
you know even back then that was you
know that's the that is the ideal for
beauty
is that something that i mean you must
have
fought against or or
fought that battle throughout your
career was that ever always like meg
ryan of course i very
quickly found my niece yes yeah you know
i'm a comedian yeah with a funny voice
yeah who's good at physical comedy so it
really helps right to know
that your what box you are yeah yeah
yeah i mean it just happened that way
and that's you know circling back to all
those things that were out there and
travolta and and all those people and i
just fit right into that so i was put
into that box which was fine because i
started working
a lot and you were very outgoing and did
travolta was he flirty with you was he
no actually he was with that older woman
who was on i think eight is enough it
was called to something oh yeah
and she was very ill when he was doing
that movie she got cancer very young
they had to replace her on that show oh
my god she died oh man and while you're
shooting that movie he was very
distracted actually oh wow
um
and i felt bad for him uh you know
because when he wasn't working he would
clearly be very distracted and and seem
very
tired and sad and and depressed well
sorry i brought it up no no it's okay
listen these are little behind-the-scene
things yeah i know i like that people
don't know about you
and one time i was on a red carpet uh i
guess it was the golden globes because
there were movie stars and tv stars
there
and um
he was kind of right next to me on the
red carpet so i decided to walk into his
interview and say are you as getting
better as you are on the dance floor
that was your line in the morning yeah
and his wife's jaw dropped
she thought i'm freaking coming on to
her husband
well in her buddy he knew
he knew she had she not and then uh he
said i'm so i'm
just so uh proud of all your success
because
you know when we talk about sunday night
fever you know i had a small part but
because i became so famous subsequent to
that i'm always kind of included in the
saturday night fever whatever he may not
have even remembered you
you know because he's not become famous
yeah yeah yeah maybe not but
also
they always show
his solo dance and i'm standing he spins
me off this is the colorful floor when
he's got the white suit
not the white suit no he's wearing a a
a grey blue shirt okay and he spins me
out onto the dance floor and i'm not
supposed to be such a great dancer it
was like are you a great dancer
i'm a pretty good dancer but you have to
protect you don't have to
know how to dance to dance with travolta
yeah he is the best freaking leader on
the dance floor i have ever experienced
he is one hell of a dancer
he i say to him so am i
are you are you as good and bad as you
are on the dance floor
and he says well if you're as good as
bad as you are in the dance floor you
must be one lousy [ __ ] that's the line
and i said well how come they always
send me flowers the next day and he's a
zonal maybe they thought he was dead
[Laughter]
and he spins me off i'm done with this
wait was that in the script that was in
the script but but i i guess so yeah and
he he spins me off
in defiance because i am me yeah i don't
walk away i stand there that led to a an
incredible career and then it led at one
point to spinal tap huh what was that
was that just pure improv auditions
no it's just talking
something when my agent golden said that
there's a really interesting low-budget
film
with excellent comic talent and rob
reiner it's his first film directorial
debut
as an actor i knew him as an actor and
he had directed a couple of episodes on
tv but that was really it yeah we had 27
pages of outline every scene
had a few bits of information that you
must include in your improv to keep
pushing the plot forward yeah
but not lines just no not lines i knew
what that album cover was going to look
like that
was a problem
you know the girl in all fours with
sniffing the gloves
i i knew
that i had to say that
um
the fact that i said you know what was
the white album there was nothing on
that freaking album yeah that was on me
um money talks [ __ ] walks hours on
me
we've been talking in the last couple
days because fran and i did a movie
called safe spaces which um deals with
safe spaces on college campuses and the
sensitivity that people have because
they get triggered by certain things and
we're just talking about
um
sex scenes with the actresses and and
all these changes now so we've been
having to talk about that fran i did
press for the other day
is it difficult for you to talk about
for me i guess it's such a sensitive
thing that it's i'm so afraid of like
potentially
saying the wrong thing that might get
taken out of context and is was that
something that you were
worried about is was that or was i the
only one oh
you mean what i was saying in terms of
answering it yeah like even that even to
say to a girl that you're doing a woman
that you're doing say that i'm
correcting myself say the woman that
you're doing a sex scene with
uh
you know to talk about it
what the boundaries are now what the
parameters are now um well look you know
the thing is
and you said something at the time you
said look and you mentioned having been
a victim of a violent crime that's not
domestic violence no so you know the the
the most extreme version of that of an
aggression against a woman and you had
said you know and of course there's a
huge gray area right well there's a big
spectrum yeah from you know uh
not being uh fully aware
and needing to learn and being accepting
yeah of that you know because life is
about learning and and owning your badge
yeah even if unintentional all you can
do is own it yeah and then it's up to
the other person if they want to believe
you or the public open your heart open
their heart
and be forgiving yeah you know
owning your bad and and apologizing with
sincerity
authentic sincerity is one side of the
coin
then opening your heart and being
forgiving yeah is another side of the
coin and you know we all do our best did
you ever think you'd see a day in this
business where there would be this kind
of reckoning this like necessary
reckoning but um
did you ever did you anticipate this in
any way
well i always knew that you know like i
grew up
in the burgeoning times of women's lib
yeah
burning bras i was not i was young but i
was observing i was i had enough right
to i wasn't out there burning my bra i
was still a kid but i saw it i
experienced it second hand and i knew
what was happening and i also knew when
the
equal rights amendment didn't get passed
i knew what that meant
uh i know what uh you know why
roe versus wade is
an issue of contention
in this country and i can hear
you know both sides of it and
um is that why you you used your
platform in 2008 to support hillary
clinton uh and and i think again when
she ran for president right when during
her senate run
i i definitely uh yeah was a surrogate
speaker for her the first time yeah she
wrote and was that the first time that
you really
got active in i mean used your no i had
known her in washington because i
actually am a
you know successful lobbyist in
washington and and and and passed a law
by unanimous consent which means all 100
senators said yes fran i was written up
twice in the congressional record
the gynecologic cancer education and
awareness act the first of its kind in
u.s history and i'm a gynecologic cancer
survivor so i kind of jumped on a bill
that was about to die
wow and brought awareness and and
breathe life into it
and um why would a bill like that die
because
you need to have
that person
that it gets in your face in just the
right way and even hillary said you know
she has a lot of people
when she was a senator that would come
to her office
a lot of women
to talk about women's health issues
being a celebrity is very useful in
washington because they all want to
photo op with you
so you'll get that meeting yeah
and uh now there is a celebrity in
uh well
yes uh that's how into celebrity yeah
we're watching the biggest realities
yeah show
yeah that to me is something that like
it's it's it's funny to be and i'm not
gonna say where we are but in this part
of new york because i associate it with
trump i i lived so long
thinking of trump in a certain way he
was kind of like was on the nanny get
out of here yes
because
he was kind of mr new york everyone knew
him there were a lot of people that were
more highly regarded as real estate
tycoons in new york city within the real
estate world but in terms of
you know the the nation and public
persona totally uh he was the one that
we cast yeah uh to play himself sure
and uh
i stood between him and mr sheffield
and my line was all you millionaires are
alike
and we got a note peter got a note
that said um had to be billionaire
mr trump is not a millionaire he's a
billionaire
peter intuitively framed it
uh and i said i'm not going to put
billionaire because that seems to on the
money
would uh
the dawn as people were calling him back
then
um the donald trump yes uh
um
would it be cool with zillionaires
because that sounded more like fran
to me yeah you know it sounded more like
queens yeah
i don't think i would say billionaire
but i danced a zillionaire yeah and he
probably he was fine with that
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and now you're on the nanny which you're
in everyone's home and this is around
the time when there were just a few
network you know just a few channels and
uh i'm curious how that changed life for
you it was a 180. really because you
know
uh because first of all the show is
wildly successful all over the world and
continues to be watched to this day i've
never been off the air for 25 years
anywhere in the world
the bushmen in south africa in botswana
knew who i was
homeless people
know who i am you're that nanny oh my
god so and then i go to countries like
you know france and hang out in paris
and other people have their thoughts on
what americans are treated like
they love me
oh my god that's the name of the show
there and it was a huge hit and it's
still on and god forbid you laugh at
something oh i know that's there she is
peter would say to me you know we're
late for a plane and he'd say
you know just don't speak and we were
going up an escalator and all i said was
uh-huh and i was
[Laughter]
i think you have a lovely voice and
people when they imitate it myself
included do like sort of a grading thing
and it's not it's uh you know it's funny
that you say that because
one time it kind of hit me that i really
have a funny voice and then i was like
freaked out and wondering why i ever get
dudes but i do
and people come up to me all the time
and say you know oh so good to hear your
voice and i think well thank god this
spell isn't broken
when did it occur to you what do you
mean there was a moment it occurred to
you yeah because i was there was a time
many years ago where i went into the
crouton business i was
i was baking them and selling them at
supermarkets
and um i sold a supermarket and when i
went back
the manager said oh i know you
you're the lady
who sells croutons with the funny voice
not the actress not the comedian but
when he said i was like the lady that
sold croutons with the funny voice i'm
like oh my god i really have a funny
voice it's not just because i'm an
actress no it's not i know this about
the croutons because the other day
summit we got that asked that by a
journalist well how do you take is it in
the movie that franny i did um that you
can see all over the country on imax um
uh there's a mo there's a scene where my
characters are constantly buying bagels
and eating bagels and she asked us what
our bagel order was what our favorite
bagels oh right right yours was organic
it has to be organic has to be organic
and what type of bagel and and
everything bagel hollowed out hollowed
out and well toasted and i laughed and i
said well what do you do with the
hollowed-out part and i said and you
make croutons hello
that is exactly what you said you do
have a good memory and i do yeah you
said hello after um with the nanny's
ending you find out you have cancer
do you remember how i mean obviously
well it took me two years and eight
doctors to get a proper diagnosis of
uterine cancers i got in the startups
more times than django
and uh so
you know
the doctor number eight uh who was so
convinced i had like five minutes of
fertility left was convincing me and my
boyfriend 16 years my junior
to this is after peter yes okay
yeah we're already separated when i
started to get symptoms okay and then i
had a boyfriend and uh he was 16 years
your junior he was he was
and he
interestingly enough
was the person that got me through
my battle
my
destiny and his destiny
were
in synergy with each other because
when he was in college he had a
girlfriend whose sister
was murdered she
had a reaction to it that
included pushing him away yeah
eventually he let her go yeah
it was what he thought she wanted yeah
afterwards and for years he thought to
himself
if i'm ever with another woman and she's
going through a crisis i'm not going to
let her push me away i'm going to be
there for her every step of the way
that recipient was me did you try to
push him away no in fact he
you know quit his job he moved in with
me oh my god and nobody has a bad word
to say about him and i write about him
in my book cancer schmancer
and he thought of the title of the book
oh really
how did you meet him uh he worked for me
he was transcribing
notes for your book
well hey listen
yeah sure yeah you know when you find
out it is that and and is there a part
of you that's relieved to at least know
uh or is it just like holy [ __ ] i
thought i was i thought i was a goner
yeah the test that she gave me that
diagnosed me with cancer the endometrial
biopsy doctor number one
said i was too young for
and i didn't say well what would that
prove or disprove i was just glad to be
too young for anything
so but actually that was the test that
proved that i had cancer and three days
later she calls me and says you know you
have adenocarcinoma and i said what's
that and she said uterine cancer and i
literally dropped to my knees
and
wept and then i had to call my parents
which i'm again you know i'm not about
because you don't want to put the hurt
right putting stress on them that's a
real acting job
because you said your mother is also
very high strung like your sister she's
nervous nervous so she's so
she's a frightened person
but much to my she picked up the phone
she said okay well let's not panic what
did the doctor say you know again i
wasn't like into having them sacrifice
the vacation they were supposed to go on
with my sister
and uh i wasn't ready to make it about
me i had to still learn at this point do
you start you do you feel like you're
doomed are you are you hopeful i
remember going into my bathroom and i
just bought a mascara it was still in
the box
and i thought that thing's gonna be here
and i won't
i think that's sometimes about objects
you know because i'm a bit of a hoarder
and i think this stupid thing that i've
chosen to hold on to is going to live
yeah
are you afraid of death very much yeah
yeah i'm afraid of not existing we were
talking about this last night i said
something like exist of stoned existence
is so great do you have a fear of being
alone
i'm able to be alone and happy alone but
i
only for periods brief periods
breakthroughs yeah couple days i can do
a couple days and then i start climbing
the walls and i need
being alone in that sense in in um
being completely disconnected from
anybody else's stuff yeah yeah how did
your fear matter now you gotta get
religious you gotta get religious well
you faced it you had enough time to
really formulate what you thought was
going to happen or what you feared was
going to happen what did that look like
when you don't have the distractions of
the day
at night is when your imagination starts
to wander totally and get the better of
you and i always tell people you know if
you don't have a pet get one i mean if
you don't have a warm body in that bed
with you yeah to grab onto and bring you
back into reality do you still talk to
the that guy who helped you through this
oh yes yeah yes he recently got married
oh wow
yeah we stayed together for about two
years after that and then broke up when
i was vulnerable
and fragile everything was working as
well yeah once i started to get better
then my power began to
uh reemerge yeah and uh you know i wrote
i started writing the buzz is that when
you got into buddhism too that the
buddhism came
uh
you know several years later um what is
your most commonly used emoji do you use
emojis when you're texting yes
what's your go-to well i uh definitely
always have an okay
a thumbs up
yes yeah a thumbs up
a uh praying hands okay uh clapping
hands
and uh
i they the the face that has a wink and
a kiss oh yeah lips
a heart
huh
an airplane
so sometimes you know i like to see if i
can write
in hieroglyphics
so i
i'm gonna put you know like i'm i put
the praying hands the plane
and then a thumbs up you're gonna be
fine you're safe traveling pray that
you're going to have safe travels it's
going to be okay that's good
so i try and re yeah and also you use
your hands a lot and i swear to you
we're going to end up going back to that
it is hieroglyphics you know yeah
they're all you know we're very slowly
being manipulated people are now tell a
universal language yeah see yeah lol
right yeah i'm i'm winking at that
[Laughter]
those are my favorite but then i do some
food things sometimes oh yeah specific
food things yeah um if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play and why i think that uh it
would be uh tennis uh-huh i like tennis
because
you're really in competition with
yourself huh yeah when you play tennis
it's just uh you know how much better
you're going to keep trying to be you
said something interesting the other day
that we were talking about sports and
you said i don't follow sports unless
i'm dating somebody who is
the sport and then i become obsessed
with their sport isn't that i'm a very
good girlfriend yeah
you know the guy that got me through the
cancer was from massachusetts so he got
me hooked on the patriots sure in the
year
that was 9 11.
and the nation
needed the patriots they won that year
they did indeed yeah and it was also a
very compelling story because tom brady
was the rookie
that had to step in that's right for a
late round million-dollar man i think he
was called
yeah
yeah listen how come do you ever
consider doing tv i'd love to really i
occasionally do gwyneth paltrow recently
said at one of the awards things that
she was on
film people can get into any restaurant
and television people
own them oh that's funny
is that did you laugh like that when she
said it
i actually wasn't watching but somebody
told it to me and i thought that's so
clever just one more question for you if
you could be a muppet any muppet which
muppet do you identify with and were you
on the muppets yes
oh you're so lucky i was a nanny oh yeah
oh really there's no i took an interview
no oh when you're on the net oh yeah oh
that's great that's great yeah yeah one
of the uh
i guess lesser couples i didn't know but
they had a baby
a baby muppet okay one of the lesser
moments
and i was interviewed and got the job oh
that's funny not statler and waldorf the
old men in the no i don't think they
were overtly not a homosexual couple um
no and then i did a john lanza's video
with kermit and um and miss picky oh wow
oh wow so i'm i'm down with the muppets
well uh i'm down with you so many people
are ditto uh at the best thank you you
didn't have to do this and um thanks
frank thank you thanks for having me and
you're here i'm glad it worked out me
too peace be well
oh my god so that happens
your impression of her makes her voice
sound so much more appealing i know my
god it's actually once you get to know
her i gotta say after meeting her my
opinion of her voice and her laugh
specifically
changed so radically oh interesting to
be honest with you like i said earlier
it's it's i found it irritating
but now having heard her and heard her
story and
and met her and and and experienced how
warm she is i kind of like it yeah it it
really it suits her and it's not i think
part of my the fact that i was i think
somewhat turned off by it as well you
know
was um to the point where i think that
may have contributed to me not really
getting into the show which i now want
to go back and watch you audition for
the nanny no no like watching the show
yeah to play the nanny
uh my voice was too normal there was
also something about it that felt forced
or i thought it was like a an affect
like she had she was forcing yeah oh my
god that story is so funny when she
talks about her performance i know his
name is like what i don't think she is i
know you never knew that's so funny but
it's it it's true it's natural it's it's
her i found it so funny that you
couldn't stop mimicking like aping her
laugh ash
it's so infectious i know and then you
would laugh at her laugh and her laugh
would
kind of
would crescendo above your lap so
there are moments in that interview
where you had like competing laughs
yeah and you're like
yeah it's so hard not to laugh which it
it's because it's funny it's also just a
funny sound
yeah and and you're right she is so and
it's such again it's a natural laugh
it's not she's one of the we've talked
about this a few times people who laugh
with abandon you know how infectious
that is how joyous that is and she was
drinking lemon water
and i thought
i had a moment where i thought
she could be eating cat food and i would
think to myself maybe i should start
eating cat food
because she
looks so good
for her age and not like oh my god and
not like you know how a lot of
quote-unquote well-preserved older
people look where they've had a lot of
weird stuff yeah
it's like oh so-and-so got a new face
yeah yeah yeah and we all know who those
people are yeah but she maybe they'll be
guests on the show one day hopefully but
she looks so naturally good still yeah
so for her age it's amazing so i thought
i've gotta start drinking lemon water i
did it for a little while i drank lemon
water in the morning well there's one
takeaway from this interview is that
drink lemon people should drink lemon
water yeah she looks fantastic hopefully
they don't screw up but you just said
and start eating cat food
um
but but you're right she got she looks
good um i love her
philosophy about life and learning and
the world being a classroom and that's
what life should be is that everyone
should you know learn and work on
themselves and
obviously she has done tons of work on
herself but she doesn't seem like uh
weighted down by some of the these
really awful things she's been through
some of these
trials and tribulations that she's
no i mean that that rape story is
the
yeah i just i i can't believe anyone
could survive something like that and
then
work through it to the point where
they're functioning and be let alone
that alone is
so remarkable
and inspirational that yeah i really
hope that people
heard that and
yeah found i i found comfort in it
because that it's happened i mean i know
we both know people close to us that
it's happened to and um
yeah i do hope that there can be comfort
taken in the fact that she
overcame it in such a complete way uh to
the point where like you said she is now
just such a well-adjusted i think it
took a long time and i'm sure there's
part of her that's still working on it
you never fully get over something like
that i don't know i don't know how you
can but she talked about the universe
giving her signs and
the cancer was the thing
she almost in a weird way almost needed
to
address certain things that she hadn't
addressed in her life and and it forced
her i thought that was really
interesting when she was talking about
her family and how she played
that the role of the caretaker and
growing up and and she was never able to
be kind of selfish and work on herself
and
i thought that was interesting too that
our family dynamic just happens to be
somewhat similar to hers and that
she said her mother
worried a lot and her father was stoic
and yeah we have a very similar yeah and
she was
the caretaker in a sort of similar way
that you are i would say in our family
yeah i wonder if that's one of the
reasons that commonality probably makes
you feel closer to her i mean i and i do
i especially now having done this i just
really like her so much like i i
i just i do too she's 60 year old goals
oh my god uh her i love her tombstone
her epitaph oh yeah her laugh made us
laugh i think that's almost made me cry
couldn't be more perfect and it's true
and what what a gift that is to be able
to give people at one point you do a
john a quick john travolta impression
and i abandoned it well it just wasn't
good it wasn't good it was like fun it
was like too fonzie or something yeah
you know what it is it's it's a ripoff
of dana carvey during it the coffee used
to do a try i bet you could do a better
one it's like oh my god oh
it's like isn't it like isn't doesn't he
well now he's he's it's but this is like
yeah back in the day he sounds much
different now it's the same way
christopher walken sounds different now
walking if you go back and watch like
deer hunter yeah he barely sounds like
crazy and all over the place what is
that that's weird but yeah the travolta
wasn't good and also um
i'm sure you picked up this i i made a
comment about
travolta flirting with her on on the
movie and right away she went into like
uh no not only did he not flirt with me
but he was like his girlfriend at the
time was like on the verge of sort of
stepped in it yeah well you didn't know
what kind of gossipy douchey question is
that
i love that she went to the crouton
business that she said it's so casual
you missed the uh i went to the crouton
business i didn't know there was a
crouton business
i mean it makes sense that there is but
i would have assumed that business is
like connected with the bakery you know
baking business i know that there's a
separate business for croutons i know
it's like saying i went into the
sprinkles business i should have been
more prepared for that i found it so
funny when she said it i like that she's
down with the muppets but she
didn't pick her favorite muppets i was i
was really
expecting miss piggy yeah me too she
seems
like a she'd be a big miss piggy fan
uh but anyway i could have talked to her
you know we actually spoke for a long
time and there's a lot of it that got
cut out so at the end of it she said
because we've been talking for so long
she said uh i was like oh my god it's
gonna be such a challenge to cut stuff
out of this because it's all so good and
she said
without missing a beat she goes well why
didn't you just have two a two-parter
she's like do you ever do two-part
episode double episode and then she
immediately called herself out she was
like i love that i'm like you know so
arrogant to think that you would do that
it was so refreshing and she like uh she
recognized it um yeah really fun and i
hope you guys enjoyed it thank you for
listening and we're going to post about
it on instagram we're going to post
about friends charity cancer schmancer
but we do hope you um
check that out as well check out the
voice memo at the end of this
episode if you want oh and we'd love to
continue to hear from you you can
actually email us now at life is short
at wondery.com and we would love to hear
your thoughts and we would also love to
hear how
you
make the most out of life we want to
hear from everybody and
figure out this whole life thing if you
want any advice from two middle-aged cis
white men who have no degrees in uh
psychology or no business giving advice
to anyone please
ask away or if you have any stories that
you want to share you know anything
anything you want to share um we would
love to hear from you again that's life
is short at wondery.com
[Music]
thanks for listening to life is short if
you enjoyed the show
please give us a five star review
obviously be honest
but i don't want to tell you what to do
but it would really help the show out
tell your friends to subscribe we're
available on apple podcast spotify
google podcast and every major listening
app as well as wondering.com life is
short is hosted by me justin long it's
produced by christian long and megan
monaco senior producers michelle mish
lans
audio engineers marcelino villalpando
executive produced by marsha louis and
hernan lopez for wondering
[Music]
if you ever do it your partner
look at me it's like i cannot conceive
of the fact that your audience would not
want to hear the whole thing
i have such a healthy ego
you